[Música]
os robôs vão substituir os humanos
qual o futuro do trabalho seremos
dominados pelas máquinas
seremos senhores das máquinas
inteligência artificial robôs humanidade
porque que a gente ouve isso tempo toda
a gente ouve cada vez mais as pessoas
falando disso se preocupando com isso
falando o tempo todo sobre esse assunto
a gente tem uma relação de amor e ódio
com a tecnologia desde sempre
a tecnologia fascina gente deixe lá de
trás inclusive quando a gente não tinha
tecnologia e isso aqui é uma história da
mitologia grega de talos que é um
gigante que defendia amigo gigante de
bronze ele era um robô imaginado como um
robô que defendia a ilha de creta
a gente sempre pensa na tecnologia como
algo que poderá ser gente que ajudasse a
gente vai fazer mais coisas mas ao mesmo
tempo que a gente tem uma relação de
amor com a tecnologia também desde lá de
trás a gente tem a relação de medo de
ódio e se uma história muito
interessante que platão conta sobre o
deus toque é um deus egípcio e ele é
considerado inventor da escrita e aí ele
chega para o rei tamuz e fala olha eu
inventei escrita ea escrita ela torna
agente mais sábios vai tornar gente com
memória porque a gente pode registrar a
memória ea ciência vai evoluir a gente
vai ampliar em que acontece o rejeitamos
vira pra ele fala assim eu acho que a
escrita vai causar esquecimento porque
as pessoas vão colocar as coisas no
papel na época era papel né ela papiros
e há outras coisas mas as pessoas vão
colocar aquilo por escrito e elas vão se
esquecer
então a gente tem essa questão com a
tecnologia toda vez que ela entra tem
quem adora tecnologia tem toda a parte
que né afim de tecnologia e pessoal que
tem medo de tecnologia
a gente conhece a história das
revoluções na revolução industrial
as salas lúdicas que quebravam as
máquinas que sabotava as máquinas ea
gente ou essa mesma história hoje de
pessoas que são
super o tópico as pessoas que são super
distópicas a gente tem os black - da
vida ea gente também tem aquelas coisas
da tendências o bicentenário até o
exterminador do futuro e esse tem os
dois grupos
o tempo todo falando sobre isso então na
realidade a história da humanidade ela
se confunde com a história da tecnologia
a nossa evolução ela é contínua e junta
quando a gente desenvolve novas
tecnologias a gente evolui quando a
gente evolui gente desenvolve novas
tecnologias
então o que a gente começa a perceber
que isso sempre aconteceu
mas a partir do século passado que foi o
século mais tecnológico antes de se a
coisa começa a mudar ea gente pegue esse
crescimento exponencial que era
trabalhar zinho exponencial é
pequenininho no começo é ele faz a curva
e começa a mudar muito rapidamente a
vida da gente a gente for ver hoje
só que em 2016 a gente tem robôs em seu
pé porque é uma das estrelas dos robôs
hoje para atendimento ao cliente em 2016
encontrem com pepe no cruzeiro na costa
da itália o peter canta e dança ele fala
das coisas que tem uma loja o tempo todo
ou seja começa a interagir com máquinas
2017 venceo eu não falo coreano eles na
lojinha de rua teodoro lojinha de rua
eles colocavam em coreano pra mim pegar
o celular zinho eo inglês inglês coreano
ea gente falava no passado no intermat
eu vi o baidu com um equipamento à
pessoa do baidu falam chinês em tempo
real trazendo inglês e cara de noite
falava inglês produzir pra chinês
então a gente começa a ver isso
acontecer aeroportos com assistentes
digitais
mais recentemente não sei se vocês viram
esta notícia
no japão e em uma cidade bastante
tradicional que outro um templo de 400
anos adotou um robô de um metro 90 de
altura pra c é pregador e ele incorpora
a deus da misericórdia e ficar ensinando
no budismo o budismo pra em inglês
chinês e japonês
eles fizeram isso aproximar as gerações
mais novas os jovens e também para
turista para entender o budismo quando
longo do tempo fala sobre isso o que ele
fala que ele acha excelente ele é um dos
incentivadores porque ele disse que no
momento que é uma estátua de buda última
alguma divindade
tanto aqui no fala nada e aí você tem um
robô que está ensinando as pessoas nos
preceitos budistas
então o que a gente percebe que a
tecnologia recria realidade ela sempre
recriou a realidade que quando a gente
fala de outra realidade a minha
realidade hoje eu viajo três quatro
vezes por semana isso é impossível os
anos atrás a boa parte do que nas
palestras anteriores gente viu que
coisas que eram impossíveis antes da
tecnologia ela vai transformando qual é
o grande problema hoje é muito rápido
então lembra da curva antigamente
demorava décadas para qualquer
tecnologia de 50 milhões de pessoas no
planeta agora tem tecnologia que em um
mês atinge 50 milhões de pessoas no
planeta então ser humano é uma técnica
espécie
a gente é simbiótica com a tecnologia
ela evolui a gente evoluir junto com ela
então mais ou menos como que funciona no
mundo desde sempre a gente forma um
sistema inteligente com a tecnologia
para extensão que é super importante a
gente esquece a gente se acha separada
tecnologia né
a primeira tecnologia embutida na gente
fala e ela muda tudo ok a gente hackeou
vários sistemas nossas internos até fala
então quando isso funciona
a gente tem inteligência que acontece
com a tecnologia muda a gente tem que
mudar a engrenagem também que acontece
quando a gente muda a gente cria novas
tecnologias para alinhar e agente tornar
inteligente a busca sempre é pra gente
ficar mais inteligente como é que há
gente que é mais inteligente quanto mais
a gente otimiza a relação humano com
tecnologia mais inteligente a gente fica
e como é que a gente faz isso então como
é que a gente otimismo essa relação cada
um tem que fazer o seu melhor
aproveitando o potencial máximo de cada
parte e isso vem acontecendo desde lá de
trás
se a gente for pensar como os primeiros
humanos cavavam com a mão certo e aí que
a gente fez
inventou uma tecnologia que é melhor do
que a mão para cavar a partir da hora
que você tem uma pá muda a sua função do
sistema inteligente atacava muito melhor
do que uma mão humana
só que ela pode ser inclusive mais na
ampla pode ser maior
esticar o braço ea sua função como
humano muda pra que você aumente
inteligência do sistema
não adianta ficar lá tentando cavar
certo
então isso vem acontecendo desde lá de
trás a gente vá aumentando a
inteligência do sistema aí muda um muda
o outro ea gente vem desde lá de trás
aqui e no mundo digital que está
acontecendo com o mundo digital
a gente está passando por um processo
muito difícil porque a velocidade é
muito rápido e eu falei agora né agora
pouquinho ea gente não está conseguindo
achar a engrenagem correta de uma
pesquisa do gartner bem recente do ano
passado
oitenta por cento dos colaboradores das
organizações no mundo não estão
conseguindo fazer a transformação
digital não sabem fazer não estão
preparados para isso e nem pra fazer da
própria carreira o povo está perdido nem
o trabalho em educação trabalho e
inovação
as pessoas não sabem que caminho tomar
essa é a nossa grande questão por isso
as primeiras perguntas que a gente fez
aqui
então por que que está acontecendo eu
falei da tecnologia na velocidade
exponencial o ser humano enxerga linear
então a coisa está mudando aqui embaixo
a gente não percebeu de repente parece
que de repente né
mas não é isso já estava acontecendo faz
um tempo
outra coisa que tá acontecendo por causa
da velocidade a obsolecência do nosso
conhecimento acelerou
então hoje aquilo que a gente aprende na
escola que essas coisas mais gerais a e
20 anos não vale mais nada
certos e pegaria de tecnologia que muda
muito mais rapidamente em dez anos isso
é de 1997 então era pior ainda então o
que você aprende mais rapidamente perde
a validade
pra piorar isso o nosso que está
baixando a gente tá vivendo a era da
burrice não sei que já ouviu falar isso
mas é um termo utilizado a era da
burrice e o nosso que está baixando você
pode falar qualquer coisa que é
biologicamente testado é a base da
inteligência pode até ser que a gente
não precise mais desse tipo de
inteligência eu até acredito que a gente
está mudando tipo de inteligência mas
não está funcionando é porque funcionava
antes não funciona agora independente do
que seja a medição que a gente tem que
ir pra continuar a história isso já está
acontecendo que vai acontecer daqui pra
frente os robôs passa a fazer parte da
nossa vida quando falo robô é corpo
físico mais inteligência artificial que
cortar por detrás disso ele um de nós
estamos nessa história a gente tá aqui ó
no comecinho
quando a gente fala do carro inteligente
do jogo de xadrez
a gente tá vivendo primeiro estágio da
inteligência artificial mas gilani que
amarrou que é estreita
ela faz uma coisa por vez só faz muito
bem na época ela ganha da gente no jogo
de xadrez ela ganha no gol
dirijo melhor que a gente mas ok é uma
coisa por vez o carro não faz conta né
ele faz uma coisa só
a gente está indo numa continua e
continuar essa evolução para chegar no
nível geral que em geral quando a
inteligência artificial conseguir fazer
aquilo que o ser humano faz que a gente
chama de geral pode ser 2040 2045 data
não importa muito aqui e aí a gente a
partir daí a inteligência artificial
continua a evoluir e deve chegar 2060
super inteligência nesse caminho gente
independente de 2060 a gente vai chegar
lá é previsto que a gente vai continuar
andando que que é a nossa questão como
que a gente continua fazendo aquela roda
de sistema inteligente funcionar para
que a gente continue relevante no
processo então o que a gente sabe
independente de quando isso for
acontecer cada vez mais tudo que pudesse
ser digitalizado será isso é dado o ok
tanto que todo dia eu pergunto dos meus
processos da empresa
os meus clientes tudo que eu faço
processo processo meu dá pra ser mais
automatizado do que eu
se ele responder sim e automatiza o
processo e aí eu faço outra coisa em
cima dele aqui tentando afinar o sistema
então qual é o futuro do trabalho se
tudo que pudesse automatizado será o
futuro do trabalho pra nós pelo menos é
tentar se manter relevante fazendo que
as máquinas não fazem então se a máquina
faz melhor uma coisa que a gente fazia
deixa eu fazer o que eu vou fazer aquilo
que eu sou melhor do que a máquina e aí
vou mostrar um exemplo vocês pra provar
que não dá para brigar com a máquina
quando era melhor e aí eu vou dar um
exemplo eu não sei se vocês sabem mas na
inglaterra para você ser taxista
você precisa decorar todos mapa da
cidade
ok londres e taxistas têm programa
decorar uma pá da cidade
isso até recentemente era vantagem
competitiva porque se chegava no táxi
ele sabe onde levaram só consultar guia
manual que lembra disso a gente tem que
fazer todo esse processo
hoje então como é que funciona hoje eu
chego em londres
eu sou medíocre
desconheço 34 bairros só de londres quem
faz a melhor rota eu medíocre em londres
com um aplicativo tipo ese ou o taxista
mais experto em londres sem nenhum
aplicativo
eu então hoje a gente está numa era que
uma pessoa mediana medíocre empoderada
por tecnologia é melhor do que o maior
expert na área sem tecnologia têm noção
do impacto que isso é você não entendeu
como o sistema fim dele gência você não
compete por isso os países estão
correndo atrás da tecnologia as empresas
e as pessoas de maneira geral não
adianta ser bom pra caramba
temos a tecnologia certa a outra pessoa
que é muito inferior à sua qualidade
técnica ela acaba tendo um resultado
maior
então qual é o futuro do trabalho é a
gente fazer o que a gente faz melhor
e todo mundo preocupado certo todo mundo
falando aí agora que a gente vai fazer
e se a gente não tiver mais trabalho aí
vou fazer uma comparação com vocês eu
não sei se vocês sabem mas quando a
gente começou até agricultura no planeta
a mudou completamente a sociedade antes
da agricultura todo mundo era caçador o
catador que se passava o tempo todo
atrás comida certo e às vezes achava
comida então se o problema mora era
comida que acontece quando a gente
começa a ter a agricultura a gente
consegue com menos pessoas a produzir
muito mais ficar com excesso e isso
liberou as outras pessoas para fazer
outras coisas porque uma boa parte das
pessoas foi liberada fazer outras coisas
é que a gente evoluiu que a gente
inventou todo o resto das coisas que a
gente está aqui e que a gente não vou
será que agora a gente não tá vivendo a
mesma coisa será que talvez quando a
gente começar a ter os robôs em
inteligência artificial fazendo as
coisas que a gente fica se matando pra
fazer e nem deveria ser trabalho humano
em primeiro lugar
será que a gente não vai começar a fazer
coisas que a gente nem imagina que são
possíveis
entrar num outro patamar vocês acham que
os agricultores vai dar pra história
eles imaginavam que a gente chegar até
aqui
acho que não né ea gente talvez não
imagine tudo que a gente possa fazer em
função disso então como que a gente
afirma essa roda a gente aqui nessa roda
assim olha isso aqui é uma comparação
que eu fiz um artigo que escrevi pelo
gartner
mente o que a gente tem de potencial
maior de forças na inteligência
artificial o que a gente tem de força na
inteligência humana
a inteligência artificial é uma coisa
por vez a gente faz várias eles são bons
em automação agente autonomia a gente
consegue se locomover a gente consegue
decidir a gente consegue realmente mais
autónomo eles são ótimos em volume de
dados a gente ambigüidade contexto
entender que uma coisa isso ou aquilo
velocidade com eles a gente é pensamento
crítico eles são razão a gente emoção
então o que a gente está falando aqui
máquinas são boas no que nisso aqui a
marca mais criatividade não é de ser
humano não fo não não não eu fico
nervosa quando vou falar isso aqui olha
só a gente
criatividade é o que mesmo você pegar
dados conectar de forma diferente pra
ter soluções
quem faz isso mais rápido quem tem mais
acesso a dados máquina você tem que
estar em cima da máquina pra fazer ela
fazer as conexões para você então
criatividade para a máquina está a gente
em cima dela lógico conectividade
máquina passado de um lugar para outro
com muita facilidade a gente não a gente
não tem essa facilidade e eles atualizam
muito rapidamente quem consegue fazer um
upgrade e agora vou falar japonês agora
falar chinês agora falar não é tão
máquina faz isso com muita facilidade e
humano que a gente faz com muita
facilidade deveria fazer seu ano certo
tanto que as capacidades que a gente tem
que ter hoje são soft skills todo mundo
falar soft skills office que a gente
queria software é justamente usar o
cérebro nos músculos e usar aquilo que
faz a gente ser humano então quando a
gente fala disso o cérebro é onde as
emoções são processadas cérebro emoção
empatia ética cérebro que comanda
pensamento crítico é o cérebro comanda
adaptabilidade é o cérebro que comanda
dentro de adaptabilidade tem
criatividade técnico simbiose escolher o
que a gente vai usar tecnologia ou não
mentalidade digital é o cérebro então o
que a gente fala no brim ninguém certo
ou você tem cérebro você usa o seu
cérebro ou você vai ficar para trás na
cadeia de evolução e aí quando a gente
começa a ver tem uma setinha vermelha
ali primeiro item
moção que que é a emoção é o que torna a
gente humana até as máquinas chegarem no
nosso nível então que quer ser humano
emoção empatia e ética
qual é o nosso problema a gente tá
ficando anestesiada sem emoção a gente
está na máquina a gente tá robotizado
agente ética aprender direito na escola
então é um problema que a gente não sabe
o que é que vai praticar e empatia é o
que torna gente ligado ao outro
entendendo o outro quanto mais
tecnologia - empate a gente está
sofrendo a morte da empatia
então a gente está falando uma coisa que
a gente precisa está desaparecendo quer
fazer diferença a máquina de vela o ser
humano faz a diferença nesse processo
a outra coisa pensamento crítico certo
qual é o problema tanto estamos perdendo
o pensamento crítico também se você for
olhar discurso de políticos americanos
abraão lincon falaram no nível de um
garoto de 10 11 anos você pegar os
últimos políticos eles falam de 67 anos
ele sabe falar
eles têm equipes maravilhosas porque
eles falam assim que as pessoas não
entendem se você não fala assim ok é a
gente está perdendo o pensamento crítico
olha só a gente prefere mentiras
confortáveis do que verdades
inconvenientes sabe a gente prefere isso
porque todo ano tem
viestes coletivos e se você não sabe que
tem viés cognitivos você escolhe coisa
errada e que desce cognitivo eu busco a
informação que confirma minha crença em
vez de olhar a informação que deveria
buscar ou duvidar
isso faz com que a gente acha que a
gente seja tão especial na realidade só
está com um grupo de pessoas que têm os
mesmos vieses que você tá e aí você fica
contra as outras pessoas que não têm os
mesmos vieses por isso é bom grupos
distintos pra gente se relacionar com um
pensamento crítico
gente olha só pensamento crítico não é
biológico não é que a inteligência não
nasce com ele tem que ser educador e
qual é o problema do pensamento crítico
a gente educada errado
a primeira coisa tem que ser cético quem
você tem dúvida primeiro de você fofos e
tem viés cognitiva ok então novidade
você duvidar de tudo o que você vê de
maneira agradável não xingando os outros
não ser desagradável com as outras
pessoas aqui estão ceticismo número 1
depois saber que tem viés cognitivo 3
lógica argumentação e retórica que
aprendeu aqui lógico argumentação e
retórica a gente aprende só gramado
você não aprendeu lógica como é que sabe
que uma coisa está logicamente erradas e
não sabe né
além disso não tem argumento e retórica
como você avalia duas pessoas
argumentando porque você argumenta não
consegue fazer isso
repertório sem repertório não dá pra
você fazer uma análise do que está
acontecendo comparar as coisas e por
último atitudes e valores que é aquilo
que guia gente por meio do pensamento
crítico então que a gente está falando
aqui cada um de nós é um sistema
diferente que a gente tem que afinar
otimizar cada um tem as suas
competências as suas forças e se tem que
descobrir quais são as tecnologias que
fazem bem
no meu caso me formei em engenharia essa
sou eu em 1994 elegeu e civil achava que
a tecnologia mudava o mundo e aí eu fui
pra axn doutorado em artes e nesse meio
caminho eu fui afinando o meu sistema
que eu continuo fazendo até hoje graças
ao meu pai que é uma pessoa que me
incentivou muito com tecnologia e com
artes então fez muita diferença na minha
educação e por isso desejo que vocês
também afirma o sistema de vocês ok
valeu gente super obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]